Collin MRI knack has spent his life
hunting on Victoria Island today
his hunting group is traveling the
rugged terrain of Canada's High Arctic
to reach the musk oxen they rely on for
food and employment as hunting guides
you can tell us that there were musk ox
around here you can tell from the broken
snow he prides himself on the knowledge
passed down from his father that allows
him to read the land musk ox
break the snow with their hooves to get
done for the food source to the grass
but on this day things aren't going so
well here a while ago you can see some
snow 50 doses of this trap seemed to be
heading east
after nine hours and nearly 70
kilometers
they still haven't seen one animal yeah
this used to just go five minute drive
and you can see a herd of musk up so
nothing today and they go home
empty-handed
Hunter's here say this has become
increasingly common for at least a
decade hunters here say musk oxen are
getting further away from the community
and when they do find them they're often
sick sometimes very sick
something climate change is playing an
increasing role in
muskoxen maybe the least well-known
animal in Canada's far north
but along with animals like polar bears
or caribou there are key Arctic species
Cambridge Bain univer is a community
located roughly 475 kilometres above the
Arctic Circle the predominantly Inuit
community numbers approximately 1,600
people here muskoxen plays a key role in
everything from food to the economy
to culture
because the musk oxen were so hard to
spot near Cambridge Bay we had to go to
Canada's Calgary Zoo to show you what
these animals look like up close
musk oxen are fascinating creatures they
are ice age relics they survived in the
days of the woolly mammoth and the giant
bears in that genetically a musk oxen
are very unique there is really nothing
else that's closely related to them and
they are I would say they're the
quintessential Arctic animal they are
incredibly well adapted for the Arctic
climate the majority of the world's musk
oxen population lives in Canada most
mainland populations are thriving but as
for the animals on Victoria and banks
islands the situation is worrying we're
starting to see more disease down the
world when you were hunting 25 years ago
how often would you see something like
that a year once or twice a year
muskox they don't shop and nowadays how
many times a year do you see those
diseases oh it's starting to become
normal thing to see diseases every day
every week every time you go out um
every other time I quote there's a
number of things going on and it's not
just one one factor
Susan Koontz is a professor of
veterinary sciences at Canada's
University of Calgary she specializes in
arctic animals and the impacts of
climate change she's one of the world's
leading experts on muskox health in the
area of Victoria Island and Cambridge
Bay in particular where we've been doing
some work with the community the
community members are definitely telling
us that they are seeing far more sick
muskoxen they're seeing skinny musk oxen
compared to the
one of the emerging concerns is this the
long one the long room is a long known
parasite of musk oxen but in Canada's
Arctic Archipelago it was too cold for
the worm to complete its life cycle and
make the musk oxen sick but now that's
changed back in the 90s it just really
was not warm enough for the worms to
develop on Victoria Island so even if
they made it on to the island they
probably would have just died out in
recent years so when we look at climate
records from the 2000s and and the the
most recent years it's certainly warm
enough on a southern part of the island
based on our models for the further
worms to grow and based on our surveys
that they've actually made their way to
about halfway three-quarters the way up
the island but lungworm isn't the only
thing hunters and scientists are seeing
there's also this a bacteria usually
found in pigs and poultry and orph
related to a virus found a domestic
sheep and goats the climate on in the
Arctic Archipelago in general in the
Arctic overall has been a lot warmer in
the last few decades and if your musk ox
adapted to an arctic cold dry
environment and all of a sudden the
temperatures are going up to 2030
degrees and these heat extremes that's a
stress and so we can speculate at this
point that that might be one of the
things that's stressing them and making
them more susceptible to other diseases
but these diseases are having an impact
on more than just the animals
for Inuit they're impacting their way of
life because hunting in the Arctic isn't
easy it requires expensive snowmobiles
gas and it's hard on equipment
and as muskoxen become more scarce near
Cambridge Bay hunters have to travel
farther to reach them
Julia Organa is a subsistence hunter and
a program coordinator at the kik to mute
Inuit Association we end up having to
purchase a lot of store-bought meat and
we're not used to having to rely on so
much at the store-bought meat because we
it's something we never grew up with the
cost is high but even to go find the
animals when we have to go hunting more
than once and quite a distance if if we
don't find it the first two or three
trips we go again and both my husband
and I work so we go on the weekends and
if we don't go get anything that we can
we have to go again the next week and in
the next week
the second time we go out with the
Cambridge Bay hunters we experience how
hard this can be firsthand it's minus 42
after eight hours of looking and almost
90 kilometers traveled : Emma Hynek
spots three animals
he harvests one but when the hunter
start butchering the muskox they find it
filled with disease
from past experience I find this Moscow
very slim and from the sing of the signs
of diseases I think it's best that we
leave the meet you
what's it like to have to go farther to
find musk ox and then when you find it
you can't use the meat oh that's big
waste
it's alarming and as any wait we don't
like to waste food many people here now
wonder how the changing environment will
affect the transmission of hunting
culture to the next generation
yeah my dad used to be a good kite he
I'm glad he taught me taught me his
skills taught his knowledge keeping our
traditions of coins David my neck is
Cohen's father he proudly tells stories
of taking his son out hunting and
trapping before he could even walk yeah
that was my first ever polar bear
hunting polar bear came in the middle of
the night to our account
but climate change is affecting even
experienced hunters like Colin Colin for
you that's grew up on the land that
learned so much from your father is it
hard when you see that everything you
learned is changing what's it like how
do you adjust I just have to adapt and
go with it like learn ways to get around
things the knowledge that I gained as a
child is not the same amount of
knowledge that our young people today
can get because we're going out on the
weekends and if we do go out on the
weekend the muskox there if we're lucky
most times which is not know so they're
lucky they get to see an animal you
wonder how bad is it going to get or
when are the answers coming in what can
we do about it I look at the climate
change projections the scenarios under
the most conservative projection we're
looking at the Arctic climate warming
1.7 to 3 degrees by the end of this
century 1.7 to 3 degrees is a
game-changer for the Arctic species that
are adapted here so that worries me that
worries me a lot will we lose species
yes we probably will I think the rest of
Canada needs to know of what our
situation is coming about because I want
the mascots to be around for our younger
generation